Another C++ cabin? You know what? Ben deserves to take over for me just for that one. I cede my seat. Ben, are you free in a couple months? Episodes 200 to, I don't know, we'll say at least 10, 20, 30? Anytime, anytime. There we go.
又是一个C++小屋？你知道吗？就凭这一点，Ben就理应接替我的位置。我让出我的座位。Ben，你几个月后有空吗？第200集到，我不知道，至少10、20、30集？随时，随时。这就对了。
He replaced Bryce once already, and we've signed him up for a couple episodes. If elected, I pledge to bring actual algorithms and data structures to this podcast. I am the anti-Brice. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 195 recorded on July 22nd 2024. My name is Connor and today with my co host Bryce, we record live from CPP North 2024. We start off by interviewing David Olson, and then things devolve into pure chaos. Other individuals you'll hear from are Tristan Brindle, Christian Shaker, Ben Dean, and a special guest with a special announcement. What are we doing here? Okay, we're here. This is my mic. We are here, folks, live from C++ North 2024 on the 44th floor of the Microsoft building in Toronto.
他已经代替过Bryce一次了，我们还签了他录制几集。如果当选，我承诺会给这个播客带来真正的算法和数据结构。我是反Bryce派。欢迎收听ADSP播客第195集，录制于2024年7月22日。我是Connor，今天和我的联合主持人Bryce一起，我们在2024年多伦多C++北区大会现场录制。我们先采访了David Olson，然后事情就陷入了纯粹的混乱。你还会听到Tristan Brindle、Christian Shaker、Ben Dean以及一位带着特别公告的特别嘉宾的声音。我们在干什么？好吧，我们在这儿。这是我的麦克风。各位，我们现在在多伦多微软大楼的44层，2024年C++北区大会现场。
We've got a beautiful view of, is it Billy Baker Airport? I think it is. Yeah? No, it's Billy Bishop. Billy Bishop Airport. Shows you what I know about my airport. There goes the gain, folks. And also the gain, folks.
我们有一个美丽的景色，是比利·毕晓普机场吗？我想是的。是吗？不，是比利·毕晓普。比利·毕晓普机场。这显示了我对机场的了解程度。增益（gain）要跑了，各位。增益也要跑了，各位。
And also the lovely CN Tower. You know, in New York, we've got like 10 iconic buildings. We've got the Chrysler Building. We have the Empire State Building. We have the Citigroup Building, the Lipstick Building, the One World Tower. But in Toronto, they've just got one. It's the CN Tower. But it's a very nice building. You know, we have 10, they've just got one. It's the CN Tower, but it's a very nice building.
还有美丽的加拿大国家电视塔（CN Tower）。你知道，在纽约，我们有大约10座标志性建筑。我们有克莱斯勒大厦。我们有帝国大厦。我们有花旗集团中心、口红大厦、世界贸易中心一号大楼。但在多伦多，他们只有一座。就是CN塔。但它是一座非常漂亮的建筑。你知道，我们有10座，他们只有一座。就是CN塔，但它是一座非常漂亮的建筑。
We have 10, but they've got one. It's taller than any of the 10 in New York. Let's go, David. Thank you for defending Canada. And we're here with our first guest of the night, who we're going to talk to quickly because he needs to go to bed. Mr. David Olson, our coworker. Hey. A longtime listener on the podcast. This is your first time at C++ North? Yes.
我们有10座，但他们有一座。它比纽约那10座中的任何一座都要高。加油，David。谢谢你捍卫加拿大。我们现在和今晚的第一位嘉宾在一起，我们要和他快速聊聊，因为他需要去睡觉了。David Olson先生，我们的同事。嘿。播客的长期听众。这是你第一次参加C++北区大会吗？是的。
And what were you here to talk about today? Today I talked about reflection. That's coming in C++ 26. What are the most important three things people should know about reflection? The conclusions of my talk were, one, it's common. Two, remember that it is compile time only. So you've got to up your compile time programming game. And three, the most useful thing is it helps you get rid of boilerplate code.
你今天来这里是想谈论什么？今天我谈论了反射。这将在C++ 26中实现。关于反射，人们应该知道的最重要的三件事是什么？我演讲的结论是，第一，它很常见。第二，记住它仅在编译时有效。所以你必须提高你的编译时编程水平。第三，最有用的地方是它能帮你摆脱样板代码。
Things that you did manually, the tedious manual stuff that you've been doing, some of that can be replaced with reflection. Wonderful. And I actually think this might be a first, because I think this is the first time we've had a C++ compiler engineer who is actively working on a production C++ compiler on the podcast. So, David, you work on which compiler? NVIDIA's HPC C++ compiler called NVC++.
你手动完成的事情，那些你一直在做的繁琐的手动工作，其中一些可以用反射来代替。太棒了。而且我实际上认为这可能是第一次，因为我认为这是我们第一次在播客上邀请到一位正在积极开发生产级C++编译器的C++编译器工程师。所以，David，你在哪个编译器工作？NVIDIA的HPC C++编译器，叫NVC++。
And what is it like to work on a C++ compiler? It's fun. It's challenging. Part of my job is to just sort of keep the whole thing together, keep it running. So I've got to keep all the pieces, make sure it works correctly, compiles code correctly. What is the hardest part about working through problems in a C++ compiler versus working through problems in, C++ compiler versus working through problems in like a regular application? Some things are easier. It's pretty much always reproducible because it's a single, we don't have the concurrency, we don't have random inputs,
在C++编译器上工作是什么感觉？很有趣。很有挑战性。我工作的一部分就是保持整个系统的完整，让它保持运行。所以我必须保留所有的部分，确保它工作正常，正确地编译代码。在C++编译器中解决问题与在普通应用程序中解决问题相比，最困难的部分是什么？有些事情更容易。它几乎总是可重现的，因为它是单一的，我们没有并发，我们没有随机输入，
you can reproduce your inputs. That part's easier. So you heard it here first, people. C++ compiler is an easy job. No, I said less hard. There's other domains have their own very hard problems that I don't have. But since these data structures get so big, it's hard to navigate through them and know what the compiler is doing. And some of the hardest problems aren't so much debugging in the compiler,
你可以重现你的输入。那部分更容易。所以你们先听到了，各位。C++编译器是一份轻松的工作。不，我说的是没那么难。其他领域有他们自己非常困难的问题，而我没有。但由于这些数据结构变得如此庞大，很难在其中导航并了解编译器在做什么。而且一些最困难的问题与其说是在编译器中调试，
but figuring out why applications are not behaving correctly. Is it a bug in the code? Are we generating, is the compiler generating bad code? Or things like that. That can be very hard. When application just gets the wrong answer, it can be very hard to figure out why. On the side, Connor, did you need to interject something AV-related? I was going to say we should probably move over here because I don't have headphones on.
不如说是弄清楚为什么应用程序表现不正常。是代码里的Bug吗？是我们生成的，是编译器生成了糟糕的代码吗？或者类似的事情。这可能非常困难。当应用程序只是得到了错误的结果时，弄清楚原因可能非常困难。顺便问一下，Connor，你需要插话一些关于音频视频（AV）的事情吗？我本来想说我们应该搬到这边来，因为我没戴耳机。
So, listener, if the audio quality is too not— It's Connor's fault. We made this mistake at C++ on C 2023. We stood a little bit too close to folks, and it wasn't until Sean, you and I moved to the outdoor thing that the audio quality... It still was audible? I thought you said
所以，听众们，如果音频质量太不——这是Connor的错。我们在2023年C++大会上犯过这个错误。我们站得离大家太近了，直到Sean你和我搬到户外，音频质量才……还是能听清吗？我以为你说
that that was part of the... It would be part of the ambiance to have that background noise. We still got the ambiance now, but now it's quieter. A little bit of background noise makes for good ambience. Fair enough. So, David, how long have you worked on C++ compilers? I've been in this job for eight years.
那是……那是氛围的一部分，有那种背景噪音。我们现在还有氛围，但现在更安静了。一点背景噪音能营造出好的氛围。有道理。那么，David，你从事C++编译器工作多久了？我做这份工作八年了。
Thirty years ago, my first job was on the front end of a C++ compiler. Thirty years ago? Do you know how old we were 30 years ago? You weren't born yet. I was. I was three. I was three. Good sirs. I was three. My birthday was yesterday. You knew I'd find a way to work that into the episode. And who got a cake today?
三十年前，我的第一份工作是在一个C++编译器的前端。三十年前？你知道我们30年前多大吗？你还没出生呢。我出生了。我三岁。我三岁。好先生们。我三岁。我的生日是昨天。你知道我会想办法把它塞进这一集里的。今天谁收到了蛋糕？
And I did get a cake today. My dear friend Kristen and my girlfriend surprised me with a cake. And everyone in the room sang happy birthday to him. That is true. That is true. So 30 years ago, what was that first compiler that you worked on? Well, it was the Rational C++ compiler, which nobody has heard of because it was not a good success. Why was it not a good success? I don't know. We didn't have, there wasn't enough special about it.
我今天确实收到了蛋糕。我亲爱的朋友Kristen和我的女朋友给了我一个惊喜，送了我一个蛋糕。房间里的每个人都为他唱了生日快乐歌。这是真的。这是真的。那么30年前，你工作的第一个编译器是什么？嗯，是Rational C++编译器，没人听说过，因为它不太成功。为什么它不成功？我不知道。我们没有，它没有什么特别之处。
Okay, all right. Now, Connor said a whoa when he heard Rational C++, and I think Connor at least has heard about it. I have heard of Rational. You haven't heard of Rational? I have not. I have not. The reason I went whoa is that that's a compiler.
好吧，好吧。现在，Connor听到Rational C++时发出了一声惊叹，我想Connor至少听说过它。我听说过Rational。你没听说过Rational？我没有。我没有。我发出惊叹的原因是那是一个编译器。
I was expecting, what do they call it? Not Turbo Pascal, but wasn't there a Turbo C++? There was. And that was by Borland, right? Yeah, and that became the Borland compiler. So then what did you work on after this compiler? I moved on to other programming tools. I spent a long time, I spent 20 years working on programming tools of some sort. So after the compiler, I think I worked on Rational Rose.
我本来期待的是，他们叫它什么来着？不是Turbo Pascal，但不是有个Turbo C++吗？有的。那是Borland出的，对吧？是的，那后来成了Borland编译器。那你在这个编译器之后做了什么？我转向了其他编程工具。我花了很多时间，我花了20年时间从事各种编程工具的工作。所以在编译器之后，我想我在Rational Rose上工作过。
What was Rational Rose? It's a UML modeling tool. That sounds like fun. And then worked on a different UML modeling tool and several things in the UML modeling space. I was a build engineer. Sort of got a whole bunch of teams to work together. We had a common build for a large part of the rational organization. And I wrote tooling for that and ran that. And then you...
Rational Rose是什么？它是一个UML建模工具。听起来很有趣。然后又在另一个UML建模工具上工作，并在UML建模领域做了几件事。我是一名构建工程师。算是让一大堆团队一起工作。我们在Rational组织的大部分部门都有一个通用的构建。我为那个编写了工具并运行它。然后你……
I learned a lot in that experience. What is UML for listeners who have not been exposed to it? Unified Modeling Language is what it stands for, and it is for people who want to draw pictures of their application design. Is UML a good idea? It had its uses. Some people found it very useful. It can be useful, but it wasn't widely successful. So it has fallen out of favor. It wasn't successful enough in the long run for people to keep making tools for it. So was the idea that you would almost visually program, you would visually represent parts of
我在那次经历中学到了很多。对于没有接触过UML的听众，UML是什么？它代表统一建模语言，是为那些想画出应用程序设计图的人准备的。UML是个好主意吗？它有它的用途。有些人觉得它非常有用。它可能很有用，但它并没有取得广泛的成功。所以它已经失宠了。从长远来看，它不够成功，人们无法继续为它制作工具。所以这个想法是，你几乎可以可视化编程，你可以可视化地表示
your program, or was it just solely a modeling thing? I never really understood that aspect of UML. It was some visual to it, but more a modeling thing. So you had boxes or some shape to represent your classes, and you drew the arrows between them for the relationships between your classes, and there were all sorts of other shapes to represent other things in your application and draw how they were connected together. And it was possible to generate some code directly from those models. That was the big hype is that there was this idea that you could design visually the structure
你的程序，还是它仅仅是一个建模的东西？我从来没有真正理解UML的那个方面。它有一些视觉效果，但更多的是一个建模的东西。所以你有方框或某种形状来代表你的类，你在它们之间画箭头来表示类之间的关系，还有各种其他形状来代表应用程序中的其他东西，并画出它们是如何连接在一起的。而且有可能直接从这些模型中生成一些代码。这就是最大的炒作，有一种想法是你可以可视化地设计
of your code and then use that to some extent, generate the shape of your code, and then that would be a starting point. Visual programming, not something we've talked about on this episode before, but I think a lot of people in the programming world got started in the robotics field as a kid, and there are a lot of robotics frameworks and a lot of early educational programming frameworks where you program visually. You drag different code blocks and things like that. Yeah, there's a lot. I have been a coach for middle school Lego robotics teams.
你的代码结构，然后利用这一点，在某种程度上生成代码的形状，然后那将是一个起点。可视化编程，这不是我们之前在这一集里谈论过的，但我认为编程界的很多人小时候都是从机器人领域开始的，有很多机器人框架和很多早期的教育编程框架，你可以可视化地编程。你拖动不同的代码块之类的东西。是的，有很多。我曾是中学乐高机器人队的教练。
Yeah. And yes, the programming is very visual. Is there a language? I know Scratch is a language, but is there a Lego language? Yeah, I don't remember what it's called, but it's mostly the visual. Yeah, connecting these boxes together to say what
是的。而且是的，编程是非常可视化的。有一种语言吗？我知道Scratch是一种语言，但有乐高语言吗？是的，我不记得它叫什么了，但它主要是可视化的。是的，连接这些方框来表示
your thing does, but they have boxes for loops and branches and ifs and variables. So that's a little bit different from UML because UML was more about the class hierarchy and structure, but still, the idea was that instead of just a purely textual representation of code, there was this vision of a more visual way of writing code. And actually, more recently, there's been this no-code movement, this movement to create tools to allow people to write apps without having to code things. And also with things like ChatGPT and large language models, we're seeing more tools and more ways for people to develop software without having to actually go
你的东西做什么，但它们有用于循环、分支、if语句和变量的方框。所以这和UML有点不同，因为UML更多是关于类层次结构和结构的，但仍然，这个想法是，与其仅仅是纯文本的代码表示，还有一种更可视化的编写代码的方式。而且实际上，最近出现了这种无代码运动，这种创造工具让人们无需编写代码就能编写应用程序的运动。而且随着ChatGPT和大语言模型等东西的出现，我们看到了更多工具和更多让人们开发软件而无需实际去
and manually type out code. Connor is great. Not Bryce though. Not me though. Apparently, there was some feedback from people that, oh, I should have just put my Python questions into a large language model. Well, let me tell you, people, I was making a point, and the point is that I don't have those reflexes for how I should go answering a question in Python yet. For C++, I would go to CBB reference. Yes, I don't use large language models because I'm old. I just had a birthday. Leave me alone.
手动输入代码的方式。Connor很棒。Bryce不行。我也不行。显然，有些人反馈说，哦，我应该直接把我的Python问题输入到大语言模型中。好吧，让我告诉你们，各位，我是在表达一个观点，观点就是我还没有那种如何用Python回答问题的反射能力。对于C++，我会去查CBB参考手册。是的，我不使用大语言模型，因为我老了。我刚过完生日。别管我。
Anyways, back to David. I did not know that you did Lego robotics coaching. So what, have you ever done like first robotics stuff or just like the Lego robotics stuff? Just the Lego robotics for the middle schoolers. Gotcha, gotcha. And do you think that learning that style of programming, that block programming, do you think that that is transferable knowledge that leads to, you know, learning how to actually write code? Or does it maybe teach people the wrong ideas about what programming looks like? I, in part. So yes, it's helpful. It's still,
总之，回到David身上。我不知道你做过乐高机器人教练。那么，你做过像FIRST机器人竞赛之类的事情，还是只是乐高机器人之类的？只是给中学生做的乐高机器人。明白了，明白了。你认为学习那种编程风格，那种块编程，你认为那是可转移的知识，能引导你学习如何真正编写代码吗？还是它可能教给人们关于编程是什么的错误观念？我，部分是。所以是的，它很有帮助。它仍然，
even though you do it in pictures and arrows, you still can learn to think like you sort of do in code. You have your loops and your ifs, you have a lot of the structures that you would see that you would type out in text. So it's not perfect. It won't turn someone into a programmer, but it can be helpful in learning how to program. One moment, I see an unsupervised dog that I think I need to attend to. You two talk amongst yourselves. I'll be back. What I actually was just thinking is that it seems like a Lego language for robotics would be a perfect domain to try and bootstrap an APL or a BQN onto,
即使你是用图片和箭头来做，你仍然可以学会像在代码中那样思考。你有循环和if语句，你有很多你在文本中输入时会看到的结构。所以它并不完美。它不会把某人变成程序员，但它在学习如何编程方面是有帮助的。等一下，我看到一只无人看管的狗，我想我需要去处理一下。你们俩聊聊。我马上回来。我刚才其实在想，乐高机器人语言似乎是一个尝试引导APL或BQN的完美领域，
because what are Lego blocks but, you know, three-dimensional, you know, cubes? And so, you know, APL, BQn could be perfect for that folks so maybe are we now gonna do lego apl programming i mean why not it's like it's it's like you're talking about for loops and if statements but really uh or actually what is it now that i think about it i was picturing in my head lego and just like lego building but what is lego programming is this like you have a car and you're programming? Like what is actually not that I think about what is Lego programming?
因为乐高积木不就是，你知道，三维的，你知道，立方体吗？所以，你知道，APL、BQN对那些人来说可能是完美的，所以也许我们现在要开始做乐高APL编程了？我的意思是为什么不呢？这就像你在谈论for循环和if语句，但实际上，呃，或者其实现在我想起来了，我脑子里想象的是乐高和乐高建筑，但什么是乐高编程？这就像你有一辆车，你在编程？就像我现在想的那样，什么是乐高编程？
Well, the Lego robotics competitions, they have a course on like a big piece of plywood and they build stuff and there's tasks that your robot has to complete and the robot has to be autonomous. Once you launch it from the starting point, you've programmed it and it has to complete and the robot has to be autonomous once you launch it from the starting point you've programmed it and it has to go out there's no remote control it has to go out and accomplish these various tasks so it has wheels and drives and can turn and the motors that move arms or do whatever motion to accomplish those tasks so this is actually not at all a good fit then, really, because I was picturing putting Lego blocks together, but this is more like a mini DARPA, the thing that kicked off basically computer vision in self-driving cars.
嗯，乐高机器人竞赛，他们有一块大胶合板上的课程，他们建造东西，你的机器人必须完成任务，而且机器人必须是自主的。一旦你从起点发射它，你就已经给它编好程了，它必须完成任务，而且机器人必须是自主的。一旦你从起点发射它，你就已经给它编好程了，它必须出去，没有遥控器，它必须出去完成这些各种任务，所以它有轮子和驱动装置，可以转弯，还有移动手臂或做任何动作来完成这些任务的电机，所以这其实根本不合适，真的，因为我脑子里想象的是把乐高积木拼在一起，但这更像是一个微型DARPA，基本上开启了自动驾驶汽车计算机视觉的东西。
This is like a mini version of that for high school students. Or middle school students. Or middle school students. Yes, but yes, they build the robot with Legos. Gotcha. And program it to then drive out and do things. And I imagine it's Lego plus plus. There's some kind of motors and stuff that don't ship with your typical Eiffel Tower Lego set.
这就像是为高中生准备的微型版本。或者是中学生。或者是中学生。是的，但是的，他们用乐高积木建造机器人。明白了。并给它编程，然后让它开出去做事情。我想那是乐高加加（Lego++）。有一些电机之类的东西，不是你典型的埃菲尔铁塔乐高套装里带的。
Right. Gotcha. Do you not like, Connor, have you played with Legos? Have you played with Legos that come with, like, a motor rotor engine? Yes, of course. Really? Is that a thing? Yes, Connor.
对。明白了。Connor，你没玩过乐高吗？你没玩过那种带电机转子引擎的乐高吗？是的，当然。真的吗？有这种东西？是的，Connor。
It's a thing. It's sold by Lego. Like, has not every kid played with these? I'm being a little unfair here. No, many have not done the motorized one. And it's not the bricks that you snap together mostly. It's like the bars with the holes and you put the pins. That's a different thing than Lego.
这是有的。乐高卖的。就像，不是每个孩子都玩过这些吗？我有点不公平了。不，很多人没玩过带电机的。而且那不是那种你拼在一起的积木。那是带孔的杆子，你插上销钉。那和乐高是不同的东西。
That's like connectic acts or things. It still is Lego. Okay. They make those. They just hold. They're stronger and they hold together better. Gotcha. All right.
那是像Connectic acts之类的东西。那仍然是乐高。好吧。他们制造那些。它们只是保持。它们更坚固，拼在一起效果更好。明白了。好吧。
It looks like we have to move out of here. Oh, we're being kicked out. We are being kicked out. I need to find the case for... Right there. There's the case. We're now back on the move again, folks. We've recorded in an elevator before.
看起来我们得搬走了。哦，我们要被赶走了。我们要被赶走了。我需要找到那个箱子……就在那儿。箱子在那儿。我们现在又在移动了，各位。我们以前在电梯里录过音。
Are people going somewhere, or are we all just disbanding? I'm going back to the hotel. Well, all right, let's wrap up this interview then. We're here with David. We will make sure to link once it's available online the reflection talk that was given at cpp uh 2024 uh what's next for you are you going to be at other conferences that people can look to say hi if you're going to be there and then in the coming year rest of the year i guess i i will be at CPPCon in September. Speaking on another back-to-basics generic programming.
人们是要去哪里，还是我们都要解散了？我要回酒店。好吧，那我们结束这次采访吧。我们和David在一起。一旦在线可用，我们一定会链接在cpp 2024上发表的反射演讲。你接下来要做什么？你还会参加其他会议吗？如果人们想去打个招呼，你会在那里吗？在接下来的一年里，我想我会参加9月份的CPPCon。演讲另一个关于泛型编程的基础回归。
Okay. And we'll probably be at Meeting C++ in Berlin in November. Talking about reflection again. So that's something for both the US attendees and the European. I guess you could be European attending, but we've got multiple continents here. We've got both
好的。我们可能会在11月参加柏林的Meeting C++。再次谈论反射。所以这对美国和欧洲的与会者来说都是如此。我想你可能是欧洲的与会者，但我们这里有多个大洲。我们有
North America and Europe. All right, we look to see you at one of those conferences. Bryce might say one last thing. Well, and I was just going to say, so David is a longtime listener of the podcast. And also because he's a coworker of mine, oftentimes in our weekly meetings, he'll mention things that I said on the podcast. So he is perhaps one of the listeners that I get the most direct feedback from. So it's great to finally have him on the podcast. Yes.
北美和欧洲。好的，我们期待在其中一个会议上见到你。Bryce可能想说最后一句话。嗯，我只是想说，David是这个播客的长期听众。而且因为他是我的同事，经常在我们的每周会议上，他会提到我在播客上说的事情。所以他可能是我得到最直接反馈的听众之一。所以很高兴终于让他上了播客。是的。
When the two of them make a mistake, I will be very quick to correct them on the company Slack. Yeah, I will say I have received messages from David before on the Slack being like, we actually, this is already capable. You were talking about like this is a thing.
当他们俩犯错时，我会很快在公司Slack上纠正他们。是的，我会说我以前在Slack上收到过David的消息，说，我们其实，这已经可以实现了。你们当时在谈论这是否是一回事。
It's like, it's already a thing. It's in the MVC++ compiler. Just go try it. All right. With that. Tristan. Whoa. Stay where you are, sir.
就像，这已经是一回事了。它在NVC++编译器里。去试试吧。好吧。就这样。Tristan。哇。待在那儿，先生。
I got a girlfriend and a dog approaching. You got to say hello to the listeners. All right. You've been such an important part of the podcast. I would say we have both of the girlfriends here, but that's not even true anymore. Yes, it's not even true anymore. We'll talk about that. But say hello, honey.
我有个女朋友和一只狗走过来了。你得跟听众打个招呼。好吧。你一直是播客的重要组成部分。我会说我们两位女朋友都在这儿，但这甚至不再是真的了。是的，这甚至不再是真的了。我们会谈谈那个。但打个招呼吧，亲爱的。
Hi, everyone. I know I'm the most popular person on the podcast. I hope you're all enjoying Bryce's wit. Do you have anything you'd like to say just, you know, that would potentially entertain the listeners about Bryce? Or embarrass Bryce. That's what I meant by entertain the listeners.
大家好。我知道我是播客里最受欢迎的人。希望你们都喜欢Bryce的机智。你有什么想说的，你知道，可能会娱乐听众关于Bryce的事情吗？或者让Bryce尴尬。这就是我所说的娱乐听众的意思。
I didn't say anything about it not embarrassing you. Just anything you'd like to share. Feel free. If that's the sound of a bus that I would like to bump over Bryce, you know, anything you got juicy for us? I mean, you can't expect me to reveal everything all at once. I didn't ask for everything.
我没说不让你尴尬。只是任何你想分享的东西。随意。如果那是我想撞倒Bryce的公交车的声音，你知道，你有什么劲爆的消息给我们吗？我的意思是，你不能指望我一下子揭露所有事情。我没要求所有事情。
I just asked for a small, you know, just a taste. In the future. Oh, wow. All right. She's been paid. She's been paid well, folks. Who else? We've got a few minutes.
我只是要求一点，你知道，只是尝尝味道。在未来。哦，哇。好吧。她被收买了。她被收买了，各位。还有谁？我们还有几分钟。
Or do we have to leave? I don minutes. Or do we have to leave? I don't know. Do we have to leave? This is live action. Do we have to leave? We have to leave? Okay. We have to leave.
还是我们必须离开？我没分钟。还是我们必须离开？我不知道。我们必须离开吗？这是现场直播。我们必须离开吗？我们必须离开吗？好吧。我们必须离开。
Why? What were you thinking? I have something for you. For me? He mentioned Tristan Brindle, who we've had on the podcast before. But I think only on conferences have we had you on the podcast. I don't know. Are you kidding me? This guy can't remember anything. It's embarrassing.
为什么？你在想什么？我有个东西给你。给我？他提到了Tristan Brindle，我们之前请过他上播客。但我认为只有在会议上我们才请过你上播客。我不知道。你在开玩笑吗？这家伙什么都记不住。太尴尬了。
Yeah, did we... And you've been on the algorithm one? We're here also with two of my former co-workers. One of them actually was my boss. Oh, really? Wait. Who was your boss? Fatima. She ran away, though. Yes, I knew it. Eamon might want to say hi though
是的，我们……而且你参加过算法那一集吗？我们这里还有我以前的两位同事。其中一位其实是我的老板。哦，真的吗？等等。谁是你的老板？Fatima。但她跑了。是的，我知道。不过Eamon可能想打个招呼
he's actually mentioned her before you have on the podcast yes not on the podcast but oh yeah of course i mean you were fatima's giving a talk tomorrow we'll link it in the show notes once it's online we'll be linked in the show notes and we're here with the program conference chair would you like to be on the pod too yeah yes i mean who's been on the pod we were we were trying to we were trying to introduce uh the program importantly have my realtor slash friend slash former colleague kristin shaker say hello kristin hi podcast listeners kristin's already been on the podcast don't you recall that as well yeah you can't remember any of our guests is he even a podcast co-host?
他之前确实提到过她，你在播客上提到过。是的，不是在播客上，但哦，是的，当然，我的意思是你是Fatima明天要演讲，一旦在线，我们会在节目说明中链接它。我们会在节目说明中链接，我们这里有项目会议主席，你也想上播客吗？是的，是的，我的意思是，谁上过播客？我们正在尝试，我们正在尝试介绍，呃，项目，重要的是让我的房地产经纪人/朋友/前同事Kristen Shaker打个招呼，Kristen。嗨，播客听众。Kristen已经上过播客了，你难道不记得了吗？是的，你记不住我们任何嘉宾，他甚至是一个播客联合主持人吗？
he didn't interview me in fairness you and Ben interviewed me that doesn't matter that's a good point you know Connor that I don't listen to the episodes so you can't expect me to have known that Kristen's on the podcast
公平地说，他没采访我，你和Ben采访了我。那没关系，这是一个好点。你知道Connor，我不听这些剧集，所以你不能指望我知道Kristen上过播客。
I have something to say on that I listen to your algorithms and data structures episodes which means I listen to about one in three on that. I listen to your algorithms and data structures episodes, which means I listen to about one in three because I don't listen to Bryce's travel episode, Bryce's couch episode. You have to agree with that. Yeah.
关于这一点我有个话要说，我听你们的算法和数据结构剧集，这意味着我听了大约三分之一。我听你们的算法和数据结构剧集，这意味着我听了大约三分之一，因为我不听Bryce的旅行剧集，Bryce的沙发剧集。你必须同意这一点。是的。
So, you know, I listen to the episodes where it's what your algorithms and data structures, you know, remit is. How can you tell which episode is going to be a Data Structures and Algorithm episode? I mean, Connor puts it in the notes. But that doesn't... The title doesn't really reflect what might go on in the episode.
所以，你知道，我听那些关于你们算法和数据结构职责的剧集。你怎么能分辨出哪一集会是数据结构和算法剧集？我的意思是，Connor把它写在说明里了。但这并不……标题并不能真正反映剧集中可能会发生什么。
I mean, but the show notes are quite meticulous, so if there's only three show notes... I've never read the show notes, so I wouldn't know. Connor is really the backbone of this podcast. Connor does all of the work and gets none of the credit. Listen, it's unfortunate that Ben has given that feedback. I was mentioning to Connor earlier today that we go to these conferences and people approach me all the time about the podcast.
我的意思是，但节目说明非常细致，所以如果只有三个节目说明……我从来没读过节目说明，所以我不知道。Connor真的是这个播客的支柱。Connor做了所有的工作，却没得到任何赞誉。听着，Ben给出了那个反馈很不幸。我今天早些时候跟Connor提到过，我们去这些会议，人们一直因为播客找我。
And he's like, well, that doesn't happen to me. And I felt a little bit bad. So if any of you see Connor at a conference, you have to ask him about the podcast. Yes, you do. You definitely do, yes. What I was going to say is that it's unfortunate that Ben has given this feedback
他说，嗯，那没发生在我身上。我感到有点难过。所以如果你们在会议上看到Connor，你们必须问他关于播客的事。是的，你们必须，一定要。我要说的是，Ben给出了这个反馈很不幸
because someone the other day said, honestly, Bryce is a bit of dead weight. I've heard those podcasts without you and it's just you at a different conference. Those are the best ones, in my opinion. And Ben just said he doesn't like to hear about the travel. I know from the volume of feedback that we get that, no, the people love me.
因为前几天有人说，老实说，Bryce有点拖后腿。我听过没有你的那些播客，那只是你在另一个会议上。在我看来，那些是最好的。Ben刚才说他不喜欢听旅行的事。我知道从我们得到的反馈量来看，不，人们爱我。
I think, though, that we always ask for feedback on the episodes where I think it's terrible, and then people come and say it's entertaining. We never ask about, ask about the technical ones. So we might get 10 times as much. What cast is called? Tristan has. Okay, so I have something on this.
不过，我认为我们总是要求对那些我认为很糟糕的剧集进行反馈，然后人们就来说它很有趣。我们从不问技术性的那些。所以我们可能会得到10倍的反馈。播客叫什么？Tristan有。好吧，关于这个我有个话要说。
So a couple of weeks ago, I was at the C++ on C conference in England. And a young man called Kun came up to me. He's a big fan of the show and he recognized my name badge for having been a guest. And he said, did I know if Bryce and he recognised my name badge for having been a guest, and he said, did I know if Bryce and Connor were going to be here?
几周前，我在英国的C++ on C会议上。一个叫Kun的年轻人走过来找我。他是节目的忠实粉丝，他认出了我的名字牌，因为我当过嘉宾。他说，他不知道Bryce和，他认出了我的名字牌，因为我当过嘉宾，他说，他不知道Bryce和Connor会不会来这里？
And I said, I don't think they're coming to this conference. He was like, that's a real bummer, because he really wanted to meet you. And he said he had a question, an algorithm question for Bryce. So I said, well, I'm going to see them in a couple of weeks at CPB North. Why doesn't he record his question on a video? And I can play it for Bryce, and he can answer this question. Perfect. So maybe Connor can splice the audio in later.
我说，我不认为他们会来这个会议。他说，那真是太遗憾了，因为他真的很想见你们。他说他有一个问题，一个给Bryce的算法问题。所以我说，好吧，几周后我会在CPB北区见到他们。他为什么不把他的问题录成视频呢？我可以放给Bryce听，他可以回答这个问题。完美。所以也许Connor以后可以把音频剪辑进去。
Well, we'll put it in. We're going to splice it in later. Hi, Connor. Hi, Bryce. My name is Gunnar. I'm from Belgium, and I am one of the lucky few that made it through episode 147 about the parallel unique algorithm. You got me interested when you mentioned that in the CUPS implementation there was the requirement for an additional array, making it quite memory intensive. So I tried fiddling around,
好吧，我们会放进去的。我们以后会剪辑进去。嗨，Connor。嗨，Bryce。我叫Gunnar。我来自比利时，我是少数几个听完关于并行unique算法的第147集的幸运儿之一。当你们提到在CUPS实现中需要一个额外的数组，使其内存密集时，你们引起了我的兴趣。所以我试着摆弄了一下，
getting rid of this one array. I tried to do this in the CUPS library itself, but it's, well, that didn't run well on my system, so I had to stop that. But there was another thing I was wondering. So the algorithm goes in two phases. Once you split up the data with the overlap of one and do the unique massively in parallel. And then afterwards you do a recombination where you combine all the parts after each other. But I was wondering why can't you just stop there and have some kind of iterator that jumps over the gaps in between.
摆脱这个数组。我试着在CUPS库本身中这样做，但它，嗯，在我的系统上运行得不好，所以我不得不停止了。但还有另一件事我很好奇。所以算法分两个阶段进行。一旦你用一个重叠部分分割数据，并大规模并行地进行unique。然后之后你进行重组，把所有部分一个接一个地结合起来。但我很好奇为什么不能就在那里停止，并拥有某种跳过中间间隙的迭代器。
Especially if you're doing this on a cpu with a limited number of threads i guess that's uh incurring this uh what should be a page fault perhaps for the gaps is much less work than trying to recombine all the elements and moving all those all of those so i was wondering if you have some ideas on that love to hear some feedback on that thank you and just show off your badge as well just uh so the guys can see it adsp listener there you go i wanted to have some swag but i put it on there so if they were here i'm gonna to get you some stickers alright thank you so wait pause before I let Bryce speak because he's chomping
特别是如果你是在一个线程数量有限的CPU上做这件事，我想那会引起这个，也许对于间隙来说是页面错误，这比试图重组所有元素并移动所有那些元素要少得多，所以我很好奇你们对此有什么想法。很想听到一些反馈。谢谢。顺便展示一下你的徽章，这样大家就能看到了。ADSP听众，给你。我本来想带点周边，但我把它放在那儿了，如果他们在这儿，我会给你弄些贴纸。好吧，谢谢。等等，暂停，在让Bryce说话之前，因为他急不可耐
at the bit because I didn't fully hear we will splice in the full recording so the listeners definitely heard it summarize the problem I think the question was about the question was about parallel unique in Cub and essentially I believe the question was about parallel unique in cub and essentially i
因为我没完全听清，我们会剪辑完整的录音，所以听众肯定听到了。总结一下这个问题，我认为问题是关于CUPS中的并行unique，本质上我相信问题是关于CUPS中的并行unique，本质上我
believe the question is why does this be done in two passes do not leave yet kristen the the question was why why does it have to be done in two passes i i'd have to look at the code to actually see whether it is done in two passes and why couldn't you um you combine the first pass with the second pass that does the actual data movement, right? Because there's one pass that would be a flagging pass, and there'd be one pass that would do a, yeah. And I think the answer is there's no reason why you couldn't do that. But I suspect that the two-pass implementation we were talking about was probably in thrust. It was probably in thrust's generic implementation of unique, which would do it in terms of other algorithms, which would mean it would be two-pass. I don't recall whether there's an actual unique in Cub, but I think there might be, or if there wasn't a few months ago, there might be now.
相信问题是为什么这必须分两步完成？Kristen，别走。问题是为什么必须分两步完成？我得看代码才能真正看出它是否分两步完成，以及为什么你不能……你把第一步和做实际数据移动的第二步结合起来，对吧？因为有一步是标记步骤，有一步是做，是的。我认为答案是没理由不能那样做。但我怀疑我们谈论的两步实现可能是在Thrust中。它可能是在Thrust的unique通用实现中，它会根据其他算法来做，这意味着它会是两步。我不记得CUPS里是否有实际的unique，但我认为可能有，或者如果几个月前没有，现在可能有了。
But unless there's a need for a global barrier which i can't imagine i wouldn't see any reason that you can't combine it right because it's unique is just it's just a filter of a of a sort right there should you should be able to do in a single pass yeah yeah i think because this is ties into that whole three-part thing that we were walking in Venice, where we thought actually that Unique Count had two passes, but it turns out that the Head Tales was actually just an iterator. And so it actually was one pass. And I don't think we actually ever followed up with that. We just did our three, four-part thing in Italy, and then we didn't record until September, and we never followed up. And so it actually was two passes. I'm not sure if that holds for
但除非需要一个全局屏障，我无法想象，我看不出有什么理由不能结合起来，对吧？因为unique只是一个排序的过滤器，对吧？你应该能够一步完成。是的，是的，我想因为这和我们在威尼斯走的那整个三部分的东西有关，我们当时认为Unique Count其实有两步，但结果证明Head Tails其实只是一个迭代器。所以它实际上是一步。而且我不认为我们真的跟进了那个。我们只是在意大利做了我们的三、四部分的东西，然后直到9月我们才录音，我们从来没跟进。所以它实际上是两步。我不确定这是否适用于
Thrust Unique, but it might. It might be the And so it actually was two passes. I'm not sure if that holds for Thrust Unique, but it might. It might be the case that it actually is only one pass. Now that we talk about it, I'm almost certain that Unique is just like a fancy version of Copy If, right? It's definitely a scan at the end of the day. We can dedicate.
Thrust Unique，但它可能。它可能是实际上只有一步的情况。现在我们谈到它，我几乎确定Unique就像Copy If的一个花哨版本，对吧？归根结底它绝对是一个扫描。我们可以专门。
Connor said it's definitely a scan at the end of the day. And I think. Connor said it's definitely a scan at the end of the day. And I think it's a single scan. Because, yeah, copy if is a scan. All right, Ben's got thoughts. Maybe I will make a commitment to try to add Unique to the next iteration of my Think Parallel talk about scans. Look at that. Look at that.
Connor说归根结底它绝对是一个扫描。而且我认为。Connor说归根结底它绝对是一个扫描。而且我认为这是一个单次扫描。因为，是的，copy if是一个扫描。好吧，Ben有想法。也许我会承诺尝试在我的Think Parallel关于扫描的演讲的下一次迭代中添加Unique。看看那个。看看那个。
And his name is pronounced... We legitimately need to get out of this Microsoft building because I think the people need to go to sleep. Oh yeah. We can take this on the road. Ben's got thoughts. At what point would you want to be injected into... My thought was just like, isn't everything a scan, pretty much?
他的名字发音是……我们确实需要离开这个微软大楼，因为我认为人们需要去睡觉了。哦，是的。我们可以带着这个上路。Ben有想法。你什么时候想被插入到……我的想法只是，难道一切不几乎都是扫描吗？
I mean, that's what we... Mike hasn't been on the podcast. We have Mike Dom here wearing... I'm going to describe Mike's outfit. He is wearing an off-white, okay, we'll go with a white tracksuit. On the arms, we have maple leaves in red sequins. And on the back, we have CPP North with the lovely logo.
我的意思是，这就是我们……Mike没上过播客。我们这里有Mike Dom，穿着……我要描述Mike的装束。他穿着一件米白色的，好吧，我们说是白色的运动服。袖子上，我们有红色的亮片枫叶。背面，我们有带有可爱标志的CPP North。
And on the front, in a very nice font, right above the heart, is Mike embroidered there. It is a very lovely outfit. And those sequined maple leaves are also on the legs of the pants as well. Mike, Dom, would you like to say something to the ADSP audience? You belong at CPP North. You heard it here, folks. Come to CPP North 2025, or I suppose if you're nearby, there's still time. You could get on a flight right now.
正面，在心脏上方，用非常漂亮的字体绣着Mike。这是一套非常可爱的装束。那些亮片枫叶也在裤腿上。Mike Dom，你想对ADSP观众说点什么吗？你属于CPP North。你们先听到了，各位。来参加2025年CPP North，或者我想如果你在附近，还有时间。你现在就可以坐飞机过来。
Wait, no, this is going to be published on Friday. You could invent time travel. There's probably also a few Kevon episodes. When do I get an episode about the management on the podcast? So Ramona wants to know, when does she get an episode about lean management on the podcast? I suppose whenever you'd like to, honey. Great.
等等，不，这将在周五发布。你可以发明时间旅行。可能还有几集Kevon的剧集。我什么时候能有一集关于播客管理的剧集？所以Ramona想知道，她什么时候能有一集关于精益管理的播客？我想只要你愿意，亲爱的。太棒了。
We can bring you on for a discussion about lean management. We are now on a Microsoft elevator. How many people here? 11. We've got 11 people. Yes, we should. Fatima, Mike, Miro. Fatima, Connor's former boss. many people here 11 and we've got 11 people everyone yes we should fatima mike miro fatima aiman connor's former boss kristin tristan you're doing a terrible job we've got fatima
我们可以请你来讨论精益管理。我们现在在微软电梯里。这里有多少人？11个。我们有11个人。是的，我们应该。Fatima，Mike，Miro。Fatima，Connor的前老板。这里有11个人，我们有11个人，大家，是的，我们应该，Fatima，Mike，Miro，Fatima，Aiman，Connor的前老板，Kristen，Tristan，你做得太差了，我们有Fatima
connor's former boss you got sheep you've got sheep connor's girlfriend asterix more on that later more on that later we've got we've got mike've got Mike Dom, the chair of CBP North. We've got, I'm sorry, I don't know your name. We've got Kristen Shaker, my realtor. We have my girlfriend, Ramona. We have my dog, Looney. We have Tristan Brindle, and we have Ben Dean here at the CIBC building in downtown Toronto and two other people
Connor的前老板，你有羊，你有羊，Connor的女朋友，星号，稍后详述，稍后详述，我们有，我们有Mike Dom，CBP North的主席。我们有，对不起，我不知道你的名字。我们有Kristen Shaker，我的房地产经纪人。我们有我的女朋友，Ramona。我们有我的狗，Looney。我们有Tristan Brindle，我们有Ben Dean，在多伦多市中心的CIBC大楼，还有另外两个人
whose names I don't know. Also my ears kind of popped a little bit. So should we talk about the big news Connor? I think you should let her correct you. I can't believe that's how you introduced her. Well I didn't want to spoil it for the audience. Should I do it now? Sure. Yes, you should. Correct him, please. Hello, I'm Shima. I'm Connor's fiance. So that's our big news. Yes. Not my girlfriend.
我不知道他们的名字。而且我的耳朵有点塞住了。所以我们应该谈谈大新闻吗，Connor？我想你应该让她纠正你。我不敢相信你是这样介绍她的。嗯，我不想给观众剧透。我现在应该说吗？当然。是的，你应该。请纠正他。你好，我是Shima。我是Connor的未婚妻。所以这就是我们的重大新闻。是的。不是我的女朋友。
Not Connor's girlfriend. Bryce just doesn't want to be upstage, that's all. You get one episode. What? You get one fiance episode. Then he'll go back to being... Oh, no, I don't Pianta episode. Then he'll go back. I don't need a whole episode. Then he'll go back to being.
不是Connor的女朋友。Bryce只是不想被抢风头，仅此而已。你有一集。什么？你有一集未婚妻剧集。然后他会回到……哦，不，我不需要未婚妻剧集。然后他会回到。我不需要整集。然后他会回到。
Don't worry. We need the details. Bryce doesn't know, but he is getting cut at episode 200. We're taking a small break from Bryce. It's only nine episodes away, folks. We need the details. So when did this happen? Where did this happen?
别担心。我们需要细节。Bryce不知道，但他将在第200集被砍掉。我们要从Bryce那里休息一下。各位，离第200集只有九集了。我们需要细节。所以这是什么时候发生的？这是在哪里发生的？
Did Connor do a good job? Okay, Connor, would you like to tell everyone where and when, what country we're in? I proposed in the Lofoten Islands in Norway. Why were you in Norway? To propose to you. But originally, initially? We used the NDC Oslo conference as a, what do you call it, a misdirection. That was my first tech conference as a non-tech person.
Connor做得好吗？好吧，Connor，你想告诉大家我们在哪个国家，什么时候吗？我在挪威的罗弗敦群岛求婚的。你为什么在挪威？为了向你求婚。但最初，起初？我们把NDC奥斯陆会议当作一个，你叫它什么，误导。那是我作为非技术人员参加的第一个技术会议。
I have to say the tech community is lovely. And do you want us to explain what you thought about that conference really briefly? Yeah, it was fantastic. NDC, hope to be at more conferences in the future. Lovely folks there. Yada, yada, yada, we got engaged. See how I made it mostly about tech? folks there. Yada, yada, yada. We got engaged. So did it, where did it happen? Was it on like, I need more details. It was supposed to be at the top of a hike called the Rhino Bringen
我不得不说科技社区非常可爱。你想让我们简单解释一下你对那次会议的看法吗？是的，太棒了。NDC，希望未来能参加更多的会议。那里的人都很可爱。等等等等，我们订婚了。看我怎么把它说得跟科技有关了吧？那里的人。等等等等。我们订婚了。那么，是在哪里发生的？是在，我需要更多细节。本来是打算在一次徒步旅行的顶峰，叫Rhino Bringen的地方。
hike. Yeah. But there was a couple of risks with trying to propose at the top of a hike. One, she didn't know. So I dressed fancy you know collared shirt uh some nice nice shorts and uh she was just in hiking attire as one does for a hike so that was a that was the risk because i was planning to take photos up there the other one though is there was like a couple hundred people at the top of the hike not a lot of space it was also at the crest of like a mountain sort of like would have probably the the little tripod would have fallen over anyway. So we ended up doing it back at the sea cabin that I had rented. Uh, yes. Cabin on the sea. No, the C plus plus cabin. You know what? Ben deserves to take over for me just for that one. I cede my seat. Ben, are you free in a couple
徒步。是的。但在徒步顶峰求婚有几个风险。第一，她不知道。所以我穿得很正式，你知道，有领衬衫，还有一些不错的短裤，而她只是穿着徒步装，就像徒步时那样，所以这是一个风险，因为我计划在那里拍照。另一个风险是，徒步顶峰有几百人，空间不大。而且它还在山脊上，那个小三脚架无论如何都可能会倒。所以我们最后是在我租的海边小屋里完成的。呃，是的。海边小屋。不，是C++小屋。你知道吗？Ben值得为了这个接替我的位置。我让出我的座位。Ben，你几个月后有空吗？
months? Episodes 200 to I don't know, we'll say at least 10, 20, 30. We'll let this guy, you know, cook for a couple months. Anytime. Anytime. There we go. He replaced Bryce once already, and we've signed him up for a couple episodes. Yeah,
第200集到，我不知道，我们至少说10、20、30集吧。我们会让这家伙，你知道，发挥几个月。随时都可以。随时。这就对了。他已经代替过Bryce一次了，我们已经签了他几集了。是的，
well, so we're back with Ben. If elected, I pledge to bring actual algorithms and data structures to this podcast. Honestly, actually, I do think I would win an election. Oh, should we have an election? I mean, I'll rig it so that he loses and we don't need to run a fair election here. We actually won time because Bryce has been pretty hard to get a hold of, not that the listeners care. So there have been times where it's like Wednesday night, one day we're out of content. I've been pretty hard to get a hold of.
好吧，所以我们又和Ben在一起了。如果当选，我承诺会把真正的算法和数据结构带到这个播客中。老实说，我确实认为我会赢得选举。哦，我们应该举行选举吗？我的意思是，我会操纵它让他输，我们不需要在这里进行公平的选举。我们确实赢得了时间，因为Bryce一直很难联系上，并不是说听众在乎。所以有时候是周三晚上，有一天我们没有内容了。我一直很难联系上。
This man has been traveling like different country every week. I never hear from him. I'm like, buddy, when should we record the podcast? He's like, I'm here, I'm there, I'm here, I'm there. I've been relatively easy to get a hold of. What country were you in this morning? Mexico. There you go. I said two countries over. It's true. It's true. Technically, I've been in three countries today because I had a layover in Houston.
这个人每周都在不同的国家旅行。我从来没收到他的消息。我说，伙计，我们什么时候录播客？他说，我在这，我在那，我在这，我在那。我一直相对容易联系。你今天早上在哪个国家？墨西哥。你看。我说过隔了两个国家。这是真的。这是真的。严格来说，我今天在三个国家，因为我在休斯顿转机。
But yeah, what was I saying? I was saying something about oh, yeah, because you were so hard to get a hold of, it's been a running joke in our relationship that if Bryce doesn't get back to you soon enough, that we were just going to record a podcast and Shima would be your replacement. I legitimately have been easier to get a hold of the past two to three months than you have. I don't think that's true. I think that's 100% true. I don't think that's true. I think that's definitely true.
但是，是的，我刚才在说什么？我刚才在说，哦，是的，因为你太难联系了，在我们关系中一直有个笑话，如果Bryce不能及时回复你，我们就录一期播客，让Shima代替你。过去两三个月里，我确实比你更容易联系。我不认为那是真的。我认为那是百分之百真的。我不认为那是真的。我认为那绝对是真的。
I am the reliable one, listeners. Vote Bryce for more chaos. Yeah, what's your pitch, Ben? Well, I am the anti-Brice. So, okay. So, Bryce, you just had a birthday. I have a system for my birthday where I take out my friends and I pay for dinner. And I think that is the
我是那个靠谱的人，听众们。投票给Bryce以获得更多混乱。是的，你的推销词是什么，Ben？嗯，我是反Bryce派。所以，好吧。Bryce，你刚过完生日。我过生日时有一个系统，就是带我的朋友出去，我来付晚餐钱。我认为那是
way to go. I mean it's gonna be a cheap dinner. Well you know, gotta save my money. Yeah, Nvidia stock has not been doing well. Bryce I think you can stretch to it. Maybe, maybe. Well, I was going to take this guy out to dinner, but he does not like the restaurant that I've picked. So no dinner for Connor. This is fake news, folks.
最好的方式。我的意思是那将是一顿便宜的晚餐。好吧，你知道，得省钱。是的，英伟达的股票表现不太好。Bryce，我想你可以负担得起。也许，也许。好吧，我本来打算带这家伙出去吃晚饭，但他不喜欢我选的餐厅。所以Connor没有晚餐了。这是假新闻，伙计们。
He's changing the narrative. His revisionist history. His revisionist history. No one was being taken out for dinner. And I know that for a fact because two years ago when your talk was accepted to the first edition of this conference and you came, we went to Miku and I treated you. You did not treat me. That is true.
他在改变叙事。他的修正主义历史。他的修正主义历史。没有人被带出去吃晚饭。我确定这一点，因为两年前当你的演讲被这次会议的第一届接受，你来的时候，我们去了Miku，我请了你。你没有请我。那是真的。
You did treat me. And I did take Ramona to Miku on Sunday night and did not invite you. That's all right. I'm perfectly fine if you not be invited. I am fairly certain that I still owe you like a $300 sushi dinner. I do not remember the reason that I owe you that. Of course, of course, he would have forgotten the amount and he would have forgotten the reason, folks. It was because back when we went to Prague for the final ISO C++ committee before the pandemic,
你确实请了我。而且我在周日晚上带Ramona去了Miku，没有邀请你。没关系。如果你不被邀请，我完全没问题。我相当确定我还欠你一顿300美元的寿司晚餐。我不记得我欠你那个的原因了。当然，当然，他会忘记金额，也会忘记原因，伙计们。那是因为在疫情前我们去布拉格参加最后一次ISO C++委员会时，
we had a bet that the video that we produced would get X number of views. I said there was no way it would become my number one video, which at the time I think was 44,000 views. You thought for sure you could beat that. It did not. I won, and it was to some fancy sushi restaurant that we no longer live next to because— That is also, I think, no longer in business. However, you still are owed a fancy sushi dinner, which you will receive at some point. I do hear that there is a two Michelin star sushi restaurant in Toronto that has a $680 per person price tag. So maybe if you're super nice to me, thank you on the podcast.
我们打赌说我们制作的视频会获得X数量的点击量。我说它不可能成为我的第一名视频，当时我想是44,000次点击。你以为你肯定能超过那个。它没有。我赢了，那是去一家我们不再住在旁边的昂贵寿司店，因为——那家店我想也倒闭了。不过，你仍然被欠一顿昂贵的寿司晚餐，你会在某个时候收到。我确实听说多伦多有一家米其林二星寿司店，每人要680美元。所以也许如果你对我超级好，在播客上感谢我。
Maybe I will take you there. It's pretty safe to say Bryce lost this debate, even though Ben hasn't said anything for like five minutes. He dunked on him. He's voting for me. Did you just try to bribe him to stay on the boat? I did. That was $680. That was.
也许我会带你去那里。可以肯定地说Bryce输掉了这场辩论，尽管Ben已经五分钟没说话了。他扣篮了。他在投我的票。你刚才是不是想贿赂他留在船上？我是。那是680美元。那是。
Okay, importantly, that's $680 Canadian dollars, not $680 real dollars. All right, folks. Well, we probably will throw a Twitter poll out there just to see what folks think. And then, you know, he will lose. Ben will be on for a number of episodes until... Can I make a politically incorrect joke?
好吧，重要的是，那是680加元，不是680美元。好了，伙计们。好吧，我们可能会在Twitter上发起投票，看看大家怎么想。然后，你知道，他会输。Ben会参加几集，直到……我可以讲一个政治不正确的笑话吗？
Keeping all the stuff in about replacing Bryce, though. That's definitely going to be canon. And let's see. We've already got, I think, two or three more episodes with Kevlin. That takes us to 194. This will probably be two episodes. That takes us to 196, which means you've only got about one or two recordings left. And then we'll have to say goodbye.
不过，关于替换Bryce的所有内容都保留下来。那绝对会成为正典。让我们看看。我想我们还有两三集和Kevlin的节目。这带我们到194集。这可能需要两集。这带我们到196集，这意味着你只剩下大约一两次录音了。然后我们就得说再见了。
But it's been a good run. That's all right. I'm going to start my own podcast. That would be good for ratings. I mean. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast dot com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但这已经是一段美好的旅程了。没关系。我要开始我自己的播客了。那对收视率会有好处。我的意思是。请务必在你的播客应用程序或ADSPthepodcast.com上查看这些节目说明，以获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。